um my question is i know you talk so
much about uh
you know never just always pushing and
uh
doing as much as you can what about uh
now that you're a dad
how do you turn it off when you get home
easily
my family is everything to me right by
the way the only reason i always talk
about pushing
and like you know this whole work-life
balance thing is i know everybody
you know you're listening to me for two
minutes and 37 seconds on youtube
the rest of the time you're pushing very
often
in the other direction we're all worried
about life work-life balance
it's by the way it's the only thing i
care about this was tough for me today
this was this moment has been very tough
for me i'm sitting through a tough
moment right now
now now that this is the fourth child
between my sister and i i know that you
don't have to be there right that
second to still have it but if this was
her first
like i wouldn't be here i would have
canceled like i've learned a little bit
like
you know like you're always battling
you're always making decisions do i let
we work down and all the people that
wanted to be here tonight is that the
right value exchange for being there an
hour or two earlier
like you're going through these every
day like i'm struggling with it every
day
but i'm also not struggling with it
which is meaning we're all doing the
best we can
right and nobody can tell you that like
for everybody's like oh i spend more
time with my family like yeah but that
guy spends more time than you
so who won did he win like like we're
all different we all listen
my wife lizzy is amazingly independent
she's just an amazingly independent
woman
who like is very similar to me and likes
in her stuff and like loves her stuff
like
she doesn't need me there every second
she probably doesn't want me there every
second
you know and so right and so like but
it's a balance but i will tell you this
there is one answer there's one real
answer
communication heavy over the top
all in communication i check in with her
we talk about stuff i check in with the
rest of my family members and friends
you just have to talk a lot and like
because you're feeling things what are
they feeling
i you know for a spouse you know heavy
communication
for your children when they're younger
it's hard you can't have that talk
necessarily
but i'm super aware of
the lack of time i spent with my dad
growing up i didn't know until i was 14
i know what it felt like to be the only
kid in my league to not have his dad
come to his little league games i know
what it feels like
so um and it was fine by the way
you know like that's just who i was i
was cool with that i was like dad's
trying to make it
like even at that age right and mom was
enough and like it was fine i was scared
of my dad anyway
and so you know i just think it's
communication my man it's a very touchy
subject
i talk a lot about hustling all in i
always get worried that people
you know luckily i think people have a
sense of where i sit on family
but like you know i mean and it evolves
i'm taking every day except for six off
in
august this year to go up to a house in
connecticut and spend time with my
family
that's more days off than i took for 11
years in a row combined
right so you evolved and different
things happen what i don't want to tell
you with nate's laughing is
i'm probably going to be emailing every
one of you individually in that
month asking you to buy my book you know
and so like
i'm going to hustle as well but i'll be
hustling with them around and so you got
to
you got evolve there's an evolution to
this